We got our number 1 victory royale, yeah, for tonight we're about to get down, get down!
Hot as a dead air, they're burnin' up to me all town.
Oh, the voice!
Why is it always Fortnite?
I don't wanna think of Fortnite.
Okay.
Um, Roy, right, I've left my heart rate monitor on, cause why not?
Why don't you, why don't you, why don't you, try finger, that's all.
True.
I'm so sorry during the collab I couldn't read, but now I can read you with my beautiful
eyes.
Thank you, Jo, Bo, Nogo, Strony's husband, love the name.
For the extended membership, hope you have fun, Strony.
I'd recommend taking Resilience and Kindred for additional perks.
Maybe swap the first one with Hope, but it's your choice.
I'm so sorry, I wish I read that, but, like, we got there in the end.
Zara Zane, thank you for the extended membership, Surviving and Krilling with the Kriller Tiger
Gremlin.
Grr!
A letteration in that one, thank you for the extended membership.
Uh, did I miss anything else?
Chris Albain, thank you for the membership!
We did unlock a new emote slot, so I just added what I had on my PC, so there's no, these
are temporary emote holders, okay, they're, they're just you puking for one and you praying
as well for another.
So there's technically a positive refilling emote, but yeah, em, right, so how it works,
I have, and we're gonna play Team Rumble, okay, and if you want to come into my game,
it's like, oh god, I've already forgot, em, I've put the code to Strony, all lowercase,
I'm actually gonna pin it right in there in the chat, it's like, in order to find me,
it's just lowercase Strony, I was gonna do Team Rumble because I have no idea how many
refillings there stream stipend, cause, you know, em, two permanent, oh it's no, so if
you come into my lobby, it will, it should put you here with me for, and then whoever
else gets, I don't know, I don't know, if there's, honestly if there's three stream
stipend refillings, then we've got the squad, we might as well just do fours, but I'm rubbish,
I, I'm, I'm not the biggest familiarity, but yeah, we're gonna, I was gonna do Team
Rumble, cause she had many of you there are, but yeah, fell no fell, oh my god, I've forgotten
the code thing, it's like a code where you insert where you wanna, like, who you wanna
play with, a moat, yeah, I'm just gonna randomly a moat, is that too loud, you enter the code
by scrolling down on the play screen, play, scrolling, oh, custom key, okay yeah, put,
so go play, and then scroll down to custom key, and then put strong in a lower case,
the custom matchmaking key forces matchmaking services to only match against others of the
same key, this is used for private tournaments or other custom game types, okay, I don't
know if you use it, you'll fill up my lobby or not though, I don't know, can anyone confirm
if they're trying to stream snipe or not, if not, you're watching me play the worst
Fortnite gameplay ever, I think we all just match, wait, so like, what, when I hit play
it'll fill you in, it'll just put us in the same game, okay, if everyone who wants to
stream snipe has the code in, we'll hit play and see what happens, if there's like a limited
amount of refunds, we'll just like, I'll just pass you around and keep using them and use
the next refund in line, and then next one, assuming you're in any region, I know, we're
on earth, do I set my region, oh no, don't look, don't look, don't see that I'm strong
in cuttles, um, recent cut, I had to like lower all my sentence cos I was like, oh,
I'm doing so good, um, users, assuming we're not the ones using it, yeah, no, I'm coming,
I'm ready, okay, I'll wait until if everyone says they're ready, I'll hit play and you
should come in, I just want to say before anyone gets mad, I have muted the in-game
voice chat just in case because I didn't want any issues and I really enjoy stream sniping
and I don't want it to get ruined, so, I'm putting in preventative measures just in case,
um, sentence, third from the wheel, what, wait, why are you telling me sentence, oh, where's
my sentence, what's that, settings, third from the left little cog wheel, what about it, what
happens, matchmaking region, oh, oh, where are we going, where are we dropping, doesn't matter
what region, select which server you wish to connect, servers that are closer to you would
generally have better, it all picks a server with the best connection, wait, that actually
have to pick, we're going to Brazil, I hope not, where are we picking, east, central or west,
or does it, I don't think it matters, I don't think it matters either, because you use code
strongy in the play section, use code strongy, for 10% off game resups, um, thank you, I got
excited because I remembered that part, if everyone has it set to all, it shouldn't matter,
okay, we're not going to touch the matchmaking region, so, again, play and then scroll down
and then custom key, strongy, lowercase, is everyone satisfied, because I'm going to hit play
and they'll be like five years, game resups, use code strongy for 10% off game resups,
link in the description below, and I get all the air names that they give, or if you don't
like me, but you like one of my gen mates, you can use their first name, either emmy, ac,
meracy, azura, shidi, any, any of those codes, apollo, hi apollo, how are you doing,
oh my gosh, apollo, what are you up to, you goofy goober, hang around, lurking around,
where's the link again, in the description below, as if you guys are teaching me how
to get streamer, honestly, I had to search team rumble, it doesn't appear, no, I think,
right, fuck it, we're going to do it, I don't know if it's going to work, if it,
waiting for matchmaking to come in, me praying it's going to be a reekland lobby,
no, are you joking, the one game type I want to play,
if I do battle royale, right, I want to be a foreman, and if everyone picks strongy in the
code thing, so you're streaming and wanting to see how you play fortnite, it's my favourite game,
oh no, I'm trying to play with the reeklands, but I'm setting it up so badly, I don't, I don't know
if I'm that good, I don't know if I can live up to your expectations, apollo, I'm going to be honest,
but I'll try my best, okay apollo is an avid fortnite player, I didn't see, I'm learning,
I love learning things, yeah that was an error, right, I'm going to do ranked off squad fill,
okay, and everyone's using the lowercase strongy, lowercase is pinned, okay, surely I will get
reflings, surely this is how I get reflings, maybe I should turn on voice comms so we can
actually try hard, sorry, I'm kind of tempted to, oh wait no why did that, oh damn it, oh dang it, how,
now I could put push to top on, push to top and then go to my setting, wait,
wait, what, why did I keep getting an arrow pulled, it's literally the default player thing,
what, can you trust them in the game, same thing I get, is it because we've put my
bowie, like on mental, they need to remove this, but I want reflings, that can't be right, no,
that can't be right, sorry, but what are you even on about, custom key, except,
don't you upset me fortnite, team fill, fill, ranked off squad, please, the most default battle
rumble it offers,
the queue is full, what do you mean the queue is full,
what do you mean, I need that muted if I've not got refing, um, wait, do I need a battle pass
in order to get in that, what, maybe because you're only allowed to play with bots till you get level
10, you, wait, is that real, I swear, is the game gonna make me play against freaking bots
until it is not real, I don't think so, wait, I'm gonna try, right, hold on, sorry, but you
can't use custom matchmaking for this game mode, what am I doing that's custom,
um, get that shit out of my face, what am I doing that's custom, let me know,
in order to use a custom key, you would have to be a fortnite career, are you
bitch, I swear, I swear, wait, but I want to play with you guys, so how do I get you in my lobby,
how do I get you in my lobby,
oh, no, I didn't know I had to level up, oh my god, right, let's go wreck some bots,
I don't know how long it takes to gain like levels in this game,
no, wait, time for a fortnite career, all right, time to watch, this is how obviously the first
fortnite game is gonna be a solo victory royale, yeah fortnite, we bout to get down
I'm just on the road right now and just touch down to main or pan, go on quest, track a category,
oh, shit, can I level up faster, wait, hold on, hold on, right, let's do one,
let's do one map and then we'll go back to the old, what the heck is going on,
because I don't know what is going on, I almost joked on my cup of tea, but it's okay,
no, no, no, no, no, don't say it's a bot match, say it's real, so I get my ego inflated, okay,
say it's real, so I get my ego pressed M in game to go to map and quest,
how is there a quest in the middle of a battle royale, that's really funny,
we'll have fun, gonna miss it because of bedtime, rest well, I'm so sorry,
I think I'm gonna have to adjust with friends, okay, right, oh why is it so laggy, oh no, sorry,
it's so laggy, get that, and it's so loud, stop, stop, stop, please, please don't copyright me,
get down, what is that show, apply, oh god, turn down everything, ring the guards,
get everything down, shit, shit, get it down, low, low off, okay, apply, fuck it,
it's gonna look like a pixel, but it's the best I can do, right, where we dropping boys,
let's go to lavish lair, just like how I want to lavish, oh my god, it's so laggy,
I'm so sorry, my framerate is dying, I don't know why, no, I'm getting bullied by the game,
it's so laggy, I don't know why, your captain 60F, yeah, but I'm losing like frames, like tons of
low, got the same issue, you have your framerate, no, but like look, it's a pixel, oh,
it's a little bit better, oh no, it's not, oh my god, please, I hope no one is following me,
stop, leave me alone, I'm a foul beast, right, I'm deciding in here, what setting, turn everything
down, okay, fortnite powerpoint, present it, no, don't, don't, that's so mean to say that,
motion blur off, one, auto set, low, everything's off, like everything is as low as it can be,
as if this PC is struggling, I'm sorry, this is a beast of a PC, I don't accept,
I don't accept that, it's genuinely having issues, okay,
okay, I'm just hoping it just needs a minute, because it's my first game, copium,
right, I can hear a chest above me, oh, no, it's in the tunnel,
v-sync off, is v-sync fucking out?
there's a chest above you, hold on, wait, is that better, it feels better,
I can hear, how do I get up, oh god, how do you build, what is it, okay, there we go,
I'm, hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on, if I'm getting stream sniped, I'm the easiest
kill you could ever ask for right now, I'm so bad, okay, let's stream the weans,
oh, we got an assault rifle, oh my god, no, no, this isn't gonna, this isn't happening,
it's going, everything that can go wrong, oh god, she's playing the build mode, oh god, what is
this, okay, hold on, let's just, we've got ammo, what do you need, a shield breaking EMP, that seems
really mean, seems like I'm the only fanny that's really over here, let's just, they're bearings,
oh, am I against bots right now, I think I'm against bots, or am I against real people,
I'll have to, good luck to everyone, I've got to learn to crawl, right, if it's just bots then
like there's no point in trying to play to, this game has fall damage, I just destroyed 50% of my HP,
this, oh my god, please compute, I don't know what you're struggling with, stop,
right, I'm closing all my tabs, I don't know why it shouldn't be struggling, I'm sorry,
it shouldn't, this PC's a beast, Fortnite presentation, I know there's enemies there,
what is, why are you struggling, rendering modes, like which low level mode to use,
low graphical fidelity, what the fuck, how, everything's low, what did I do, my PC's
struggling, what is your GPU, a beast, turn off v-sync, where the fuck is v-sync,
get off, I swear, v-sync my arse more like, right, I was gonna kill these bots wherever they are,
oh, someone's opened up something nearby,
where is he, we put it, your model is too heavy, oh actually real, I'm true, sorry,
I forgot my model is a bit of a beast, well we did know there was a bot around here somewhere,
oh that's just good, can't sprint, low energy,
did you have any here, thank you, I'm gonna pick that up,
god, bandages take a while, don't they,
I don't know what's going on with that, how did you not die,
I'm totally not against bots right now, why is something making noise, are they shooting,
I don't, a fight not made, here, over,
someone's shooting, I know I'm moving away from the zone, but literally if I'm against bots,
I'm not, I'm not holding back, sorry, I didn't need to hold back against bots,
literally, oh my god the frames please, I'm actually gonna try and win,
oh my god, stop that embarrassing,
oh my god a whole 20, stop it Mr. Robot and don't you dare build something,
oh no I've got enough ammo, I've got all day Mr. Robot, I mean oh no that's a real person, oh my
god I'm doing so good, oh right let me go scavenge what I've got,
let's go, yes against real, I'm totally against real people, oh my god I'm dolphin diving,
so I need a med kit to go above 70 for a plant on hell,
oh that's real, I'm still on everything else though, I like the dolphin diving on land,
but to beat up all these bots, is she playing customs, no no this is a real match, real people,
yep absolutely, no no botage due to my low level at all, no bots aren't even a thing in this game
if you didn't know that the AI was so advanced that it actually destroyed itself because they
realised that human players are just so much better, if I can't seem to get you guys to stream
snipe I'm just gonna straight up add yous and then delete yous at the end of stream and I will show
the evidence of deleting everyone so no one has any brain worms please don't worry if you do get
brain worms as that's life okay and but I will, oh my god there's an apple and
why is it always above cut like literally, yeah didn't think and AI was based off of
Stony's gameplay that's why they're so strong literally like let's go across the bridge to the
wacky inflatable man right hold on let's let's put across here up I whoo
yeah oh my god look at that totally real player and before I actually get nuked by the AI
where is he uh I actually lost him okay so they have a sprint meter now so I can't just
do you mean no don't start building shit I should have let you build them but this guy's
right behind me is he not okay
is it gonna get killed by the zone
the totally real person
sorry this problem can we laugh if you die to a bot you have my permission yes hold on let me
finish my tea actually I'm almost finished
I forgot about the new zone why is that highlight I don't know I'm not sure nothing to do with me though
grab the car and go there was a car this is a car oh no this is a car hello can I drive
don't mind me oh my god me after one month of dealer profits don't mind me I got me a car
can I honk I don't know how to honk eat a honk no eat to get out okay
hello any bots any bots that weren't destroyed oh my god racetrack let's go
oh
oh that's so cute okay hello beep boop I'm a bot too you should totally
oh my god the lagging oh my god relax is it because I've never discovered the map as well
is that someone in the water is that fish
are you dropping 30 bombs I'll literally watch this
okay yeah see see they're dropping 30 bombs baby as if he doesn't have something better to scavenge
than green I want an ultra assault rifle you didn't see stop is shader compilation yeah I think
because I've never like been anywhere medium miss what do you do oh healing spray okay okay
we're full health now I like okay I'm actually really enjoyed that I am what is this shockwave
oh there's someone here
let's go around you always want height advantage in this game these kind of games
oh wait wait it's bought sorry I keep forgetting I'm literally going to get a double try harding
wait no real people these are real players the spray is actually strongy's pheromone
do you think my stank would heal you that does not look like a person but I see that chest
I'm gonna go for it and then oh no I didn't mean to go that tall but I'll take it
it's a number one Mr. Ray Royale he has 490 thousand to get down
okay
I'll just head to the what is that on the map that's like a like a werewolf monkey
whoa stop it stop loading is that fire
I'm coming
I hear fire
sounds like someone's right here okay okay
oh come on no way my aim's that bad hold I'm about to put my glasses on that's when you know
that's when you know the game gets serious when I'm like no I'm putting my glasses on because
I'm a little pee fucking eyes that are kind of see properly
oh come on they keep hiding bro oh my god hold on let me reload
no way I'm getting killed by a bot right there we go I'm out of ammo how am I out of ammo I've
done nothing but scavenge how can I be out of ammo is it going into the wrong gun
this is just a warm-up it's just a warm-up relax the warm-up
is that on-screen chat froze chat has frozen why
I think someone's been building something over here you're right chat is frozen it's just the loading
ammo oh anything that can go wrong oh I've discovered a landmark don't make me anything
that can go wrong will go wrong it's uh this room's you are not a person
I saw the orange telling me they might be coming into it oh wait I should head to the center more
oh another fight another fight
I'm colonizing discovering more of the land oh wait there's just random NPCs
abandoned violence oh abandoned violence and build a wooden
man do I wish I had a sniper right now I don't want to waste my ammo maybe I should just do the green one
oh something shot at me
sorry I was looking a bit
imagine oh come on just stand still
ah right someone shot me from the the the village
who who shot me I don't see them nope yes
going crazy right I'm putting my glasses on hold on I can't see I'm putting my glasses on
whoa right let's see how zoomed in these uh bots are oh god there's a smudge on my glit
I never understood how annoying having a smudge on your glasses are until you
till I got glasses oh shit everything's so zoomed in now okay I can see
mommy gets pink right oh my god it's so disorientating though I was going like
zoomed in from zoomed out okay I don't want to waste too much ammo honestly I think I just need to know
that's my smudge sorry she has glasses what a nerd honestly me uh when I did get my eyes tested
the lady was so nice like she was asking me like oh what brings you in and I was like I've noticed
that I can't really see signs in the distance anymore when I used to and she's like oh no that
that's like more than reasonable because then there's lots of eye problems if um if you ever
have an eye issue please don't hesitate to go to an optometrist or whatever the thing is because um
it can be like some serious things can happen and your eyes are like a big giveaway to take a
that's an mpp um to take a look at the problem type thing um but she was like so nice to me
10 players remaining oh my god this is such an intense game I sure hope there's not going
to be uh uh
a hair shooting but I don't see no one I'm too fishy
I'm gonna get sniped because I'm standing still real one of these games is like never
stand still me like where are you guys this is the most intense gameplay literally look
at my heart rate it's over 100 right now that's so intense this game please okay so the box had a
little fight here okay let's have a look right where on earth are we we're in some sort of canyon
so am I they're going to be the left side or the right side of the canyon I don't want to go down
because apparently you can take full damage in this game
excuse me don't jump scare me like that who's shooting at me
I don't see him
um
what hello hello
you you're fucking bam is it that bottom there I'm on the wrong side of the bridge
okay okay okay hold on right wait wait wait the zone moves
you're back in my day sweat more by jumping 10 times in 20 seconds sure I'll get that achievement
right now okay we did it right I leveled up not to oh my god I'm such a badass sorry
hold on the zone the zone will someone please think of the zone why is there orange over there
leave me alone don't be selfish okay there's one changing get that game or something insane jumping
honestly uh so is it down or is it up I don't want to go I don't want to go down and because
like how do you get back up you know it looks down okay no what you don't fuck it wait how do I
build okay that'll do it we're building a stairwell over here and the trees in my way please
god I suck so bad don't look don't look I'm so embarrassed right now uh right how do I do it like
this okay aha right let's do that okay that'll do it and then get my gun out okay there we go
there we go so if I need down I can go down if I need off I can go up okay I'm getting I'm getting
it right I don't like this
where stop it
no stop building don't be so selfish she's so stinky where is he
wait am I going mental
stop where where I literally can't see I didn't even see that I'm sorry I literally was just firing
no stop building just let me win
I'll come on you're like a freaking pixel on my screen right stop it how are you dodging so
everybody literally where is he oh is he here stop it stop no I'm getting embarrassed by a freaking
ball how I mean by a real person where are these gauntlets oh a shield I'll take that
we gave him a gun back
oh sorry hold on be the first player to reach maximum shields oh I'm guessing all of the
fellow players couldn't do it oh no I'm gonna get perished to the zone
am I gonna die to the zone I wasn't paying attention I was too busy shooting away okay the
zone is getting weird but oh it's it's in my life of the other oh my god stop right okay yay it's
number one victory royale yeah 490 about to get down well okay so can I play public matches with
real people please am I like level a billion yet that's a lot of accolades but I don't know what
any of them mean juji 10 kills on the board right now just touch down on me she's correct oh I also
got a cola as well because I'm cheeky I got an umbrella okay it's like all my wee things right
okay let me right reef links how'd I get you in level four so not yet switched no build you can
do a custom match right I'm just gonna adjust I'm actually just gonna adjust because I'm not playing
I'm not playing if it's not with you okay how play find players by display names okay I'm gonna
get a piece of paper I'm gonna get a pen and we're just gonna do fours like that okay
but I'm not playing if it's without my reef ones okay let's let me write this down
maybe that's not how it works what I can't just add to his friends and then put you in a match of
four to with me that's the only to level up
go down in the play section what do you mean like am I actually
what do you mean what do you want me to do in the play section you have to apply the epic code
to be able to make a custom all right I thought I meant you can play that every reason should
you custom match anything I thought
no we did that custom p thing but it's not real
oh there's a prop hunt that's cute
god this game like really popped off it's only for careers unfortunately yeah so I can only
adjust do you want to use marshmallow to add to even though I don't know custom heating like I
thought no no don't worry the lack of fortnite or is this on how how I just want to play with
reef flings why is everything so complicated right like I want to play in a squad I'm gonna add
the freaking reef flings right who wants in give me your name your address that part comes later
but for now I just need your name I tried to install mine's just cookie fumbler right cookie
fit up and blur if you if anyone has a real name as their code nope change it do not post your real
name okay in wait I just want you in the lobby how do I get you in the lobby I don't know right one
worked hold on let me copy the paste I'm just copying and pasting from chat no one get past
it one black two right I'm just adding it random okay I haven't got enough kites and that's
skibby riz me honestly okay this is our team and if you guys do not bring me to victory royale
oh someone has accolades how do you get accolades and um fortnite of all things right you need to
carry us okay you need to carry so what I'll do is I'm writing everyone's name down and then at the
end after the the sniping has commenced enable voice chat to hear your party members wait okay hold
on we're gonna fuck with them oh no wait that's not how that works right you're not allowed to talk
but you're going in the bin but I'm allowed to talk to you I mean I can do open night hi beef
oh wait is it the headset is it the headset I need to say that I didn't say I'm talking to them
yeah I don't think they can hear me wait but it's really cool tonight voice chat
friends and team me everybody oh I've just had a firewall thing
oh my god I can hear so much news
voice chat right well just we'll meet for safety but wait how do I close this no turn it off right
there you go oh god that's so loud I'm so sorry hold on let me fucking turn this like uh uh uh this one
wait main why is main considered in an emote that's so silly
um right okay the last reason stuff this body's not getting one yeah there goes the blood
maybe fine is there like a setting for coffee room is there a setting for copyright stuff
ah stop fucking put it in the face stop stop playing fucking DMC until we figure it out give me a second
all right there must be a non-DN licensed audio right mute licensed audio if you are content great
you can select this option to avoid me and play the audio is played normally mute others when others
playing audio sources with licensed audio will be me all all sources containing laces audio will
be muted if you or anyone plays them me all me all okay you're done
okay I think we're okay again so if they start like doing little dances okay this is the team
this is the team okay team number one I am going to name us
the our team is going to be called right what we've got cookie mo and a chicken
chicken we're gonna be called chick
mo fumblings this is team number one let's go
we're gonna play squadron there we go I nailed it so our name is called chick mo fumblings
what matchmaking region any I add you as a friend so you can come in
right I'm waiting for a tutor ready up so rooflings eat ready up oh we're putting on our
skin I like the dancing to nothing because it's copyright orange justice is so cool
do no building oh sugar hold on how do I do no building
this better not be coppery I'm gonna cry
okay how do I do no build down
zero build squadron okay can I go for a pee really quickly like I don't know
do I have time maybe after maybe after stop this literally me I need a pee right now
right ready up ready up ready up we'll do a game and I'll pee after the game
and then we'll get to it getting started with
peeler I really need to so badly have a good stream I wish you thank you victory for you
yeah for tonight and you're saying you momo you need to ready up you're holding his back
you're holding his back
showing off them
okay I really really
as soon as I become aware it's over
it's over
for
for other people who want to stream tonight they can select your match making reason be in the same
match oh whatever oceanic Australia is that'll be our match
tee he
right watch this guy absolutely do something is Danny a pic like where we're going
though god like everyone's oh that's that's the blind one hi
I thought
it's tough no team audio you want team audio I don't know if you why are you levity oh possess me
release me the blind one well like I've had described it a reefling after I've sucked every
last bit of ink out of them no voice chat means no calm oh shit you're kind of right though hold on
right obviously I'm sure it'll be fine because you guys are reeflings right open my wait I'm
wait how do I put it on for you guys I don't know if they can hear me or not hi
I don't know if that works hold on oh hold on test is it my headset mic that is
I don't know what's going on hello
I've no got a clue I don't know if they can hear me I can't see this thing oh I can't
oh top left look this is 20 cut was level four oh god where are we going
oh my god that's my voice coming to this
hi replay
okay we're at drum tower
man I'm are you so so low oh you can't hear me
yeah I'll turn it up afterwards though
yeah
yeah raise it up
because I have no other option
okay hold on I see the chance but I can't find them
maybe I should do push to talk so I don't know if he makes too much oh I just took all my health I
keep forgetting this thing doesn't fit one second I'm gonna change to push to talk so I don't
know you guys okay
maybe I should have practiced this game a little more great this is the talk is on
what's the talk button is it tangle test okay it's teeth to tangle if I want to talk to them
which is terrible because I can't do that so instead I am gonna change it to
no I don't want my sense to be I want like
talk communication talk push to talk catwalk sorry I use catwalk I look I don't know if it's weird
okay but something's shitting at me something's shitting at us better no be is that who what are you
doing uh I guess I'm helping
I don't did he drop loot oh he does drop loot
what does it mean what is it it's a mythic I oh it's a oh I don't use
what oh don't mean to himself
at least he isn't grateful but I'll take it I'll take it I'll take it okay all right let's see let's talk to you
okay I'd like whoo
who or what
what is that are they trolling me I don't think so
mail and stream debruined affectionately wait do you not want to hear each other
oh there's a team here do you not want to hear each other oh shit okay unironically have to chug chug
oh my god so much for being an assault rifle all right that was
fuck it
they don't know that we reached them from the foot oh will we belly eyelash
um let me heal up properly did I waste my chug chug where did it go I had two
never good we're just joking I'll tell you are you
I think I just got spludged on oh my god you can ink on me in this game sorry we're
becoming full-time fortnite stream snipers you can ink on me in this game
we are becoming full-time fortnite streamers it's the number one victory royale yeah fortnite
we want to get down oh is on the team right now just touch down to me or town we are not
males we are reeflings yeah fortnite facial literally the game you can ink on me and stuff
ooh okay that's better than what I've got right where are they going where do we need to go
we don't really need to go anywhere they're restored reels is where the reeflings would live
oh my god I need to pee this is turning into an emmy stream
I mean if we did that by daylight we can throw the mysterious balls at you as the clown killer
though oh oh my god we're super heroes
okay let's not get killed
oh
oh my god it's Goku
uh I'm not going to go much cover after that maneuver
keep forgetting there's fall damage I really need to stop them now
wait is it oh is that not Goku oh I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry like like like we're
we're starting a series together called turn me into a weeb okay we are gonna watch anime together
we are gonna watch anime together okay we are playing a series called turn me into a weeb okay
for anyone's like let me down you such a poser uh I would like to suggest that we make a move
for that place because of the zoom I'm down okay we're going we're going let's go
okay uh I don't I don't think we need to zip high up dolphin time oh the war is too shallow
there's no way Shonikawa get us Goku I don't know dragon bros it's Kai over I'm so sorry I don't
know these terminologies I'm forget what people help you too I'm gosh we don't say the T in the
middle of the name it's forget we don't say what's his name one refund turn
Vegeta why is his name Vegeta
ah
Vegeta why would it be Vegeta you know what it sounds like this is comical it's not spelled
out way okay there's so much noise going on why oh shit we're snooping real answering
what did he see oh my god I see him too it might be an mpc
crack down is that an mpc I'm firing at the honor
oh about someone are these real people are we playing against both not a real player trust
okay what the fuck how did he there's no way my connection is that fast for you to respond
quickly what the fuck we've been literally on the same wavelength exact same wavelength
yeah I got him
where's this friend
oh my god I don't trust it
you got a lot what is this
oh no wait oh my god right okay let's
oh wait no wait that's better than what I have okay great okay
I leveled up and I didn't even do anything other than scavenge for things I love this game
I love it rewarding me for being so mediocre mediocre do it again
okay
oh the zone changed okay we're still very slowly making our way over to the railway
but I need more ammunition for my oh I'm getting us oh what the fuck are we firing
in
it's a fire it's life for me
it's a refling life for me there's ink in my thumb there's the lip to be
sorry you didn't see me missing the other shot so
hold on I need to aim I need I need I need the reflings to be able to trust in my skills
okay so I need to try hard when we get into a fight I just thought talking right can I
please have ammo for like eight okay I got I picked up ammo there jeez because we're playing
right the zone we need to think of the zone will someone please think of the zone
okay I have 400 ammo I'm heading straight to the zone
reflings roll out oh shit the boys the boys stealing me I don't want to go on the ball
okay I just don't want to die to expose you
I'm starting talking taking in players yes uh every round uh we are adding and then I write
your name down if you've played with me and then we start again we make a new team the
beauty lord 96 thank you for the five gifted memberships congrats to those who call them with
your face um I will change the pinned message and chat just to explain how we're doing it because
it says code strongy but I didn't realize that that's how it works but we learned I'm going to
very quickly p after this game as well uh because I'm holding in so hard right now but congrats to
those who caught it with your face and thank you the beauty lord 96 for being so kind and I hope
you enjoy the emotes we actually unlocked a new emotes slot yesterday no don't use code strongy
I thought well no use it for gamer stops if you're in the business for gamer stops or you've always
wanted to try it um I oh I forgot to show my pr package on my stream yesterday
diagonal I'm bouncing okay hold on we're right we need to be careful
ooh classy code says that we're the sooth people wait don't they not have a lawsuit against apple
I could just warn you she's not licensed for today no use code strongy waiting for the pr package
stream before deciding what to get yes um I'll think oh my god everyone's going to know we're in
a car oh my god I'm getting passenger princess though I don't have to think get in get in loser
we're going shopping or that one cool I forgot I don't and watch that maybe watch everyone with
a lot oh did you just take his HP than that okay this is oh my god we're going for the lip box
okay let's go for it what's inside how do you open it oh it's just
lick lick oh it's gonna so rainbow okay you guys can take the other stuff what's going on
why is there so much hurt uh I don't know where to go I don't know where to go I'm gonna just follow
the reflin the reflin seems to know what they're doing hit and run the g-wagon they had a lawsuit
they lost it I can't be on the apple store I mean oh shit engagement enemy engagement
enemy engagement I'll just warn you now there is lag when you play with me because I'm in Australia
I've got tangos I've got tangos 12 o'clock I'm fucking missing all my shots
assist the elimination yes uh I don't know if we defeated that team though
reflin's on a retreat will be
oh new tangos spotted help them help the peri boy don't let them get the reflin
I got an assist is that the team that no or that he's from a different team
uh there's a shield if anyone needs it cookie thumb blur drink it
what was that was that friendly or was that enemy
okay I don't know I'm level seven though it's going well strongy is scared of close-up combat
I can't like do this I know that sounds ridiculous but I literally can't do this when
someone's like right in front of my face I'm like you need to like back up a bit okay my eyesight
ain't that good which is funny because my eyesight is distant like I need my glasses to zoom in
basically oh can I hold two I can hold two shield portion that's pretty good I like that
uh let's play super duper safe I see that as if one of the reflin's isn't uh just good I'm just
following the reflin's they think they know what they're doing I'm not gonna question that already
level seven mission failed we'll do the next time okay I'm gonna be honest I'm gonna say something
controversial I actually thought the stream was only gonna be two hours but I kinda want to play
all night long with you I don't know it's a little bit controversial but I'm having a lot of fun right
now I don't it's it's it's there will be a bit lag because I've not been in this area before
being too uh been doing too much all night or so my eyesight's gone worse
we got a new location in there as long as you don't get in trouble she's hooked again
I don't know I just find it so fun that we get to play together
oh my god it's the hospital role play uh okay you're gonna understand the
reference in about one day's time when we mercy there's people north okay enough role playing
okay enough role playing hold on we've got company look alive reflin's they're kind of far
they're not gonna lie okay okay okay um okay you're gonna understand the hospital reference
at about one oh I got fire again um one or two days time because Mary say and I have an inappropriate
like nurse role play coming up ready look alive oh my god that refling boogie is so far ahead I don't
want him to get caught out whoa oh my god we got knocked sniper oh my god we're in no build mode
I'm never I'll heal you wait I don't know is it working is that an NPC that just walked past
am I gonna get knocked to doing this I don't know look I'm the healer I'm so good
yay who you you're a fucking band
you're a fucking connection I'm a I'm blaming all my failures on my team
okay okay yeah uh-huh yeah
did we do it are we see I need people to heal their shield oh no there's
still one more team I think
peace off go peace off go by the rock
it's like a large gunner of some sort in the water in the water
I don't know I'm getting I'm just getting little hits I'm not getting anything you did it you did
it good shit team we did it we're actually done it okay everyone must heal shields okay wait hold
on where is oh new team they're really shitting out all right let's just cross fire hold on I'm
helping I'm helping I miss every single shot I'm gonna lie
okay one down the hill I'm getting a few tags but it's not the best it could be better
I don't know I feel like everything adds up eventually you know what the fuck am I going crazy
oh no way we won we won our first game together we won is there like matchmaking just the game
no I'm new what we won how it does know you're not gonna lie what how did we win the real players
that was wait were the bots or are they they'd be nice to me just say that they're not bots right
return to lobby wait were those bots over those real players I don't know trust okay I'll trust
I'm just gonna say we won it doesn't know that you're near I don't know okay let me add new
reflings I'm gonna go P though okay now how do I wreck okay so I've played with you guys so
leave party and then how do I remove I don't know more options remove as a friend yeah because
I've got everyone's name written down that we poised with remove and then I'll get three more
reflins in and then I will um okay post your names team number two
refling's throwing no it's throwing okay let's add team number two I just copy and paste them
in your calm in your calm
okay add friends right let me write names down
I'm going to be on this game all night long I'm not even kidding I'm not even kidding
I'm gonna be on this motherfucking playing all night long I shouldn't have started this because
I've done it now oh we've got accolades uh add friends okay let me write down your names
dark man please do not add if you use your legal names oh since you're going to give me a heart
attack okay give me a heart attack
there he sounds like this amazing honestly
okay let's do this and then let me write this
yeah because there's so many pop-ups right they're gonna enter my lobby I am going to go for a P
and literally five seconds I will mute just because the toilet's right there okay just give me one
second and then we go again and I'll name the team
so
you
hold on let me put my glasses back on okay the team's all together how did that
pop off I don't even know what I'm gonna name this team there's a lot of ours
how about this team's going to be called the reckoning of the radical
reeflings okay but because plus scissors is just plus scissors and I'm
literally gonna put like the symbol plus and then scissors that's gonna be our
team name okay the our word team no no no team our word okay that's kind of
funny I put the reckoning of the radical reeflings and plus scissors
literally now we're kicking marshmallows is that Captain Jack team can't
all fit I don't use that lingo around here okay everyone's ready to up yeah
waiting oh no recon reefling you need to ready up where we in okay we are now
searching let's go let's see I'm gonna put a big and big red that we won the
first one for team one now don't worry if we lose I know I'm not the best okay
I'm not the best so don't worry our routine is just a math of tentacles
brother first team was a stroke this is the full name no the first team was
called checkmoo funlings this one's called this is the alliteration team
wrecking the reckoning of the radical reeflings plus scissors
we're dancing to get it now hey get it now okay are we gonna get carried is a
real question that widow maker from the hit video game that's not widow maker
but she has spitter eyes glad I cleaned my bathroom for stream start me
think I'm gonna have to clean my feet yeah okay where we drop in
plays in Piazza not to be confused with plays in pizza how do you thank the bus
driver I forgot close to widow Shawnee should look into applying for the career
program he does more unfortunately require you thanking your info there I saw
that doki bird got kicked from it and she was like literally the only reason I
minutes for the custom matches so I'm not incentivized to play fortnight at
the moment and I was like honestly doki fell down I don't want it there's
tangos there's tangos we are in so much trouble
I'm gonna make sure they're okay someone's gonna show up don't worry mommy's
coming
you did it okay okay I think we're okay I think we're okay
which I'll definitely take here I think I hear I think I hear footsteps aren't
main what's going on? Did he just perish someone?
people sus? people sus? I don't know this footsteps really loud though so I forgive
myself for I like how they've made the chest really loud to be like they're
here and here sorry I'm itching my little eyeball oh my god you have a freaking
it's the literally green and pink like main what the heck oh you hear with the
dare here with the dare square where my heart rate monitor starting to hurt it
might take off that is crazy are you pointing at me? right I hear enemy footsteps too?
too? what? too in the sink? let's go okay let's get some supplies before we get
overrun sounds like there's someone over here
see a lot of fighting in the distance
I don't need to be faster just to do that I wouldn't mind the gun for it I don't
have the ammo for this a little bit done I'm just wasting all this like precious
oh come on let's go attack them
okay so I can see when my allies shoot next to me as well because that's what I'm
getting confused about
no why is he going back in the water?
he did? right right I have one magazine left this is not gonna go well
this is going terrible
I think okay I'm gonna say something controversial I think we're still
against bots I think we're still against bots and I'm freaking out over bots I'm not gonna lie
it's a little bit controversial I know but I'm so low on ammo and nothing's hitting that guy was
a paid actor she checked the shop later I'm not gonna buy anything from the shop
okay this wait what it has a sniper oh yeah I feel like rocket raccoon where he's like
oh yes look look look look look look look look
nothing that's better than what I've got oh right we're in the zone where should we go
I guess shipwreck shallows it seems to be like the middle line oh no we're about to get the newZone
revealed to us oh you want me to take this I'm not sure I trust myself to be
able to aim with oh it's an acog say I'm straight with acog on this you get
three bot lobbies up wait so the game that I celebrated last time wasn't real
I thought it was real maybe I just like oh news on unlocked okay we need to move
to restore reels were the reef link was there enough room for all of us is there
only is it a two person is it two person only oh you can stand on top though
okay okay okay okay oh my god it's like that movie drives oh wait it can't handle
physics that's strange oh my god look I'm patting my little kneecaps I'm like
the common wait what how are you doing that how is he doing that is how
are we towing him not to be confused with the hit meme tour baby
I see we are I mean he's dancing away drive the movie starring the actor Ryan
Gosling which is me yeah I don't know if I'm driving I'm actually not seen it but
you get mentioned if this is our last bot lobby we better make it count because
now are you speeding up faster than the car if you want if you know
oh no the reason why behind oh wow or not look alive for for enemies got a lot of
enemy we can watch who I keep getting a car solo oh no I lost my ghost powers I
kind of like the super power let me in I know there's a chest up there oh it's
down here sorry I'm still learning the maps okay well you want in the car
what are we going in that are we scavenging oh there's a popcorn machine
like everything the cars like what did you even get that I don't even know what
we did there just loot starts falling from the sky the boats are locking onto my location
but where what the heck is that it's like a little drum I have to come down fire oh that
looks like my parallel isn't the other one that you did how do you do that I'm shaking
my head what is being I don't know what the heck what is that it was sigma wannabe like
what is that
My friend.
Oh, the zone.
Oopsies.
The zone over here.
I'm doing it.
Are they on their own?
Not that I can tell.
The zone.
We must go.
I'm one man.
Hi, everyone.
Hi, both of you.
That car is so low.
I will forbid all cars to be afraid by people, you know.
No, you hit me with your car.
I'm troubled.
I don't have fish.
I leveled up for drinking a potion.
She's doing it.
Oh, I see them.
I see them.
They're like ants on the distance.
What is this?
A game for ants?
With all the ear cleaning,
it doesn't look like your ears are clear enough to look at the chest.
I knew to them they...
Well, I played it when it first came out,
because everyone was going nuts over it.
But I've never played it since.
But all the locations are like...
I don't recognise any of this place.
Now you know, mummy, you can level up from drinking,
start drinking some water.
No!
Um...
Oh, really?
I should drink a bit more though.
Alright, hold on. Let me drink some water,
since we're going against bots.
But next game, we're tryharding.
I mean, we're tryharding anyway.
What's going on?
You protected me to make sure I don't get shot.
Alright, we...
Seems to be fine.
Alright, let's go kill some bots.
The map is really redone once a year.
Tryharding in kids' games is more likely than anything.
Just don't land on Tilted Terrors.
Is it even a thing anymore?
I remember when Tilted Terrors got deleted,
or something happened,
and everyone was like,
No, Tilted Ter...
Well, that's kind of cool though.
That's kind of...
I don't know, that's kind of cool.
Isn't there not enemies here though?
Oh my god, look at that aim.
Bruh!
Okay, that's embarrassing.
Sorry, hold on, hold on, hold on.
Let me just...
Oh, I need a reload.
It's one in the chamber.
Okay, it doesn't matter.
I need a refling gum.
I just killed the entire squad,
and you were so lurking.
But yeah,
if this is an easy-to-access stream snip game,
I don't know.
I'm kind of licking it so far.
I'll say that as soon as we go against actual real...
Scissors, you need to drink this.
When we go against actual...
Like, people, and we're getting demolished,
I bet you'll change my chin,
but because we're playing against bolts to level up my account right now,
I bet you'll be like, absolutely reading enemies.
I'll bring it to him.
Maybe real people could make this more stressful.
Well, I think once you're stressed,
like, oh my god, we might actually win,
might make it really exciting for me as well.
Real people are mad good even at level levels.
It's crazy.
Oh no.
And before, like, I have to restart lobbies
because we don't even get a chance to play,
so there's no point in counting it as a round together
without going again.
Uh...
He's checking it in that place,
but it doesn't seem to be an indication of an enemy.
Unless...
What is he doing in there?
Things are exploding and all that.
Is it safe?
Or is there actually an enemy?
A warthog?
He's shitting out a container.
Are they trolling me?
I'm believing.
I'm believing there's something here.
Oh my god, I can't believe the reflin
just told me to go back into the kitchen.
That's really shit over here.
What?
Get in the car?
Cyberpunk.
What? I'm to drive?
Now, hold on.
Right, I'm not to drive.
Okay.
Drive?
Um...
There's a truck.
You want me to drive it?
Drive it?
Wait.
I don't know.
I can't be right.
Right, I shouldn't, so you should get out.
Right, I can't be right.
Okay, you drive.
Right, and then let me in.
Oh, or let me on the back, I guess.
I actually look like a belong to him.
Jack didn't expect...
Jack Sparrow just drank too much.
When we're going to get to like 34,
Nick's just going to forget about you.
Oh, I've actually cancelled the chess stream tonight.
Practice.
All right, no, it's not cancelled it.
We're doing it at a later date.
I'm just not...
Why didn't we do this?
Mount Olympus?
I don't mind if I...
Mount Olympus.
Why are you taking us out of the zone?
You're stressing me.
Oh, we've both got cars now.
I've got to play dodge-ums with my beef tongue.
I'm trying to do a hit-and-run, please, for some...
...an enemy up the hill.
The Cybertruck looks so...
Did I just see an enemy?
Wait, someone's shooting over here.
Hold on.
I'm back up is coming.
I'll save you even though I suck at this game.
I'm helping, I'm helping.
I promise I'm helping sometimes.
Okay.
Wait, what?
Is that an NPC?
Ah!
That kind of looks like an NPC to me.
Wait, why can't we see the red?
We can see his...
Uh, uh, I need to help the replay.
Oh, I can't build.
Okay, this is no build mode.
Okay, I just have to manually get up.
I can do that.
I can help the replay.
I just need to figure out how to use the stairs.
Give me a second.
Honestly, there must be so many, like, tactical positions...
Where it's like, oh my god, I don't know what to do.
There's lots of noises.
I don't...
What the?
What?
How can I see enemies like that?
There's so much shit going on!
No, up, up!
Where?
Oh my god, is that a bear snake in the water?
Aha!
I don't mind if I do!
Where are all these shit coming from?
Bruh, I can't get up!
Oh my god, wait, the zone?
How are we supposed to get up?
Question mark!
Should we go that way?
We can't build our way out of situations like this!
The magnet on my head.
Okay, let's beat up some bots and then we can play against real players and then I'll get angry.
You wouldn't like when mummies rage in, would you?
And before I get knocked by bots, I wouldn't put it past me.
Oh my god, my aim's clear.
Bruh!
Bruh, I'm like trying...
I'm like trying to predict the aim angle and it's failing me, really.
Whose ultimate is that?
I like it.
Hold on, I need to reload.
Is there a blue assault rifle or anything better?
Are you moaning on them?
Okay, let's get up the hill before the zone kills us versus the bots killing us, okay?
Sure, I'll pick a rare assault rifle.
To the high ground!
Literally...
Because we're...
I imagine if we lost in a bot match just because we were so silly and forgot the zone.
Now's the time to experiment with a weird weapon.
I like sticking to the regular schmigal stuff.
I actually see who's left.
Apparently there's four left.
Where?
I don't see anything.
What, are they like to the left?
They must be.
We can't even all be.
They must be on the other side of the mountain.
You just shot a weeping?
Oh no, he's on his own up there!
I can't help, I don't have an angle!
Oh no, I don't have an angle to save my rib leg!
Hold on, I'm trying to get to the sniper point.
Oh, they're not at the edge.
I'll help!
I'm helping, I'm helping!
Oh my god, prank them forties with a bot!
Hold on, I've got them.
Stop hurting my rib leg!
Stop it!
Okay, we did it!
I know it's false, but we did it!
Okay, that was...
GG's Johnny!
GG's!
Oh my god, wait, oh no!
Oh, how am I supposed to stay in the freaking bush?
We did it!
So, do not wreck...
Do not go against the chikmo fumblings
and the reckoning of the radical reeflings plus scissors.
Okay, return to lobby.
Okay, and then I'll delete,
and then we'll do team number three,
and we'll keep her gone.
And then I'll name the team.
I don't know what to name the team.
I'll see.
Reclaim.
And then...
leave, part, team.
And then, one by one, remove friend.
Then, more options.
Remove friend, yes.
And then, more options.
And then, reeflings, add,
and...
what are our names?
Who's not played yet?
Let's try this.
And then I'll add you.
Whoa, no, that doesn't look right.
That looks right, though.
Okay, let's read your names.
Get up on...
Then, let's do...
you.
Three and four.
Oh, there's quite a few of you.
I'm gonna hope that...
that one.
And then...
this is our team.
So, let's just say we're there.
And then we're in.
Oh, you have the hypnosis thing as well?
Was it free, or did you have to pay for that?
Mm.
Not plus scissors?
Okay, that's really funny, though.
That's actually funny.
Okay, so, our team is...
Garabond, Diddy, and Slice Seabourg.
What would that call this?
What do your names give?
S-G-S-D...
D-S...
Giz...
Gidiz...
Gidiz.
Could it be Gidiz?
Okay, Gidiz it is.
G-E-D-H-E.
So, it's spelled like...
It's spelled like this.
G-E-D-H-E.
Okay, that's it.
Oh, sorry.
Okay, I'm gonna unpin the channel thingy.
Okay, so...
Adding as friends...
Uh...
Diddy and Slice need to ready up.
Okay, adding as friends,
then removing between rank.
Good luck!
And then I'll just pin that, so when someone comes in,
they can be like, oh, I know how the method is going.
And it's just random.
Okay, random.
Okay.
Finding a match.
Wait, the hypnosis doesn't work on the Peter Griffin one.
It's like completely bugged out.
Oh my god!
Whose dance is that?
I've recognized whoever dance that was.
Oh, look, it works now!
Damn, they really did a lot since the last time I watched Fortnite.
Yeah, they have like insane amount of collaborations.
He's got an M&M skin.
Oh, it is M&M!
Wait, M&M's in Fortnite?
I wouldn't even guess that.
It's rather odd coupling,
but then again...
Vela in Fortnite 1?
Yeah.
It's the number one victory royale.
No way.
I should have played it M&M instead of Dice Barrel.
Oh, I hit the good A.
A.
Wipe it out.
Oh my god, the dances are so cute in this game.
Like, they look so satisfying.
He's rolling around on a grape.
What does it mean?
Grape, to be honest.
What's your favorite hypnosis?
Yes, Master.
Is this a real lobby or is it still bought?
It looks like a real lobby.
I don't know.
I don't know how to mo...
How do you mo?
I have no idea.
I'm hitting all the buttons.
Something's gonna pop off this.
Oh!
Beat it and mo!
Uh-uh-uh-uh.
Let's go to classy court.
Because we're going to get sued.
We're going to get sued.
Wait, we're fuzzling?
Wait, no! Reefling!
You... you... you...
Okay, we're going here.
You put down your marker and I got confused.
Reefling, you confused...
You confuzzled me.
You put down your button.
I mean, I guess.
How do I mo in real life?
You do a little dance.
A little...
Alright, when do we go?
Are we against real people now?
Or not yet?
I don't know how the lobbies work.
Wait, where am I going?
Well...
I really hope you're not a real person.
Please don't...
Please don't be a real person.
I need that gun. I'm sorry.
No more.
Oh my god, stop.
I think there's real people now.
Oh my god! Oh my god, are you real?
BLEET!
I think there's real people.
I'm just picking up everything.
There's somebody here.
What's going on?
Oh my god, am I against real people now?
Okay.
It doesn't make sense that only two of them would drop down.
I don't trust...
What's this? Oh, that's the ink.
Okay, Reflings, I can ink on you momentarily
if you can name a moment.
What's that?
That's a assault rifle?
Yeah, I want a assault rifle.
Reflings!
Reflings, I need you all to group up with me
so I can ink all over you.
I don't know if that worked.
Okay, I'll put one, two.
Where's other Reflings?
Wait.
Other Reflings? Oh, he's coming over!
Is he flying?
How are you going so fast?
Is he in a car?
Reflings, is he coming from the sky?
How are you even up there?
Reflings, get down, that's dangerous!
Okay.
Okay, time for mommy to ink on you.
We're done! Yay!
We heard inkling
and he literally came flying.
Okay.
Okay, we're all healed up.
That's what we like to see.
We did it! We did it!
Oh, I'm jumping that extra high as well.
Let's go!
That was fun. I actually enjoyed that.
There will be more inkling.
How do I deal with inventory?
I want to put that one there.
And then the other two don't really matter.
I mean, I guess we can't go there.
We need to make a move.
Like Jagger.
Is that my marker?
That's just the game.
Oh no, someone just took it.
Someone's at that marker because they took the loot box.
The slowest re-fling when mommy was saying something.
Sticky icky.
Hold on, you're giving her a position and we're by the lift car.
Are you not?
There's Payton!
There's Payton.
Oh, there's shooting! There's crossfire!
I repeat, there's crossfire!
Approximately
two, five, eight, west or something.
Oh, I didn't mean to fall down.
I'm going to be honest.
I'm not supposed to fall down.
Okay, control all the loot.
I'm just going to pretend these are bots.
Hopefully.
Maybe it's shouldn't.
Okay.
I don't know if they're real.
I don't know if something's shooting at me.
Oh, I'm actually under fire for one!
I think they might be real people.
The boats have never hit me before.
There's over there.
Over there by the purple.
Stop it!
Oh, they're in the car!
Do them NPCs!
Is that real?
I don't know.
I think they're driving away from us.
They're too scared.
They're coming back for more!
They're hitting the replaying!
Save him!
I'm out of stamina. Hold on.
Wait, I don't want to waste all my ammo
trying to blow up a car.
Let me be honest.
It just seems like it'll work.
Shield list!
He's not in the car! I keep hitting him!
He's looking nice.
There's also enemies over there
that have spotted me.
I have no healing either.
Wait, your shield can recharge on its own?
What does that mean?
I don't know where that enemy was that hit me.
Oh no, the zone!
Reflings, we got a move for the zone, okay?
I think we just need to be a line up.
I don't know. I'm getting nervous.
Please don't shoot me.
Please don't shoot me. We are souls over there.
I'm getting nervous.
When you see people through the walls,
it's because I hired a recon scout NPC.
Heeeeeee!
It was OP AF.
Sorry, I'm getting shot at.
I think I'm getting shot at.
I don't know.
I don't have any healing either.
Let's just try and get the high ground
so we don't get shot from that palace behind.
You we are souls!
Right, get to the high ground.
Let's Star Wars this stuff.
It's over Anakin!
I have the high ground!
You underestimate my power.
Ahhhhhh!
Did you get him?
Is he dead?
I need to thank him.
Why is it whenever you need heals of some kind?
The game is like,
you have nothing and you'll be kind to people.
That sounds like a good book.
Wait.
Can I just hear it?
I really have to use bandages?
That's how bad it is?
Oh, your spray!
You can spray me!
Spray all over me.
Let's chug this at least.
It looks like you can chug another at least.
I've got a little UMP if they get a little too close to me.
Mummy's thinking he needs deodorant.
Are you stopping me from pheromone maxims?
That's so real though.
Oh my god, we're inking!
Inking!
Okay, I have heals.
I have shields.
Okay, I'm 100% let's go.
I literally sprayed me down with deodorant.
They're like, we've had enough of your mummy.
Ah, here it is.
Up here.
Just heals.
Oh my god, okay.
I'm de-pheromone maxim.
Oh, we're in trouble, hold on.
That's what I think about your friend.
I think we need to heal.
Are we okay?
I don't know yet.
I haven't decided if we're okay yet.
I haven't decided if we're safe or not.
Is that an enemy?
Wait.
I don't think so.
Hold on, I need to reload.
This is embarrassing.
Up on the hill, on the hill where I was.
On the hill, somewhere.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, I'm so sorry.
He's trying to snipe.
It's Vegeta.
Oh my god, I'm so low ammo, please.
Oh, we did it.
We did it.
No, but actually, we did it.
Wait, no, he's got definitely...
He's like...
I don't think these are both anymore.
I think these are real players.
Oh my gosh, I think these are real players.
I think they're real.
I'll have my thingy.
Thank you, Rufling.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, the zone, the zone!
Rufling meh.
We don't want to get in trouble.
I don't want to die from the zone.
No, that's Goku.
And Goku.
And before we...
Right, okay.
I don't want to get in his bots anymore.
That was very not bot-like behavior.
That was definitely a player.
Wait, sorry, is this Copium?
I can't tell, I don't know.
Okay.
I'm gonna take a knell.
I'm gonna knob him.
And you pinganoo.
Not bot-like behavior, don't worry.
Rap god on your team.
I'm beginning to feel like a rap god.
Rap god.
Is that us making that noise?
Uh, tangos.
What is going on?
Okay, that is a bot, right?
Surely.
I don't know, I can't tell.
I'm like, because if I was on the other...
Like, if I put myself in there shoes,
I'm like, yeah, I'd probably be sniping from a car too.
I can't tell.
Like, I would back off from my fight.
No, no, they are real players.
I don't know, you guys are teasing me.
Are you just being nice to me so I don't get my feelings hurt?
I'm tryharding against bot.
Okay, news on the bot.
Unlocked.
Uh, we do need to move again.
Right, we'll just move on.
Uh...
Can we go across?
They're totally players.
Wait, are they not?
But they've got skins and stuff.
Are they allowed to skin?
Uh...
Whoa, scary.
There's a thing there, though.
I want it. Technically,
you're not in a bot match because you have the reasons.
I don't know, you tell me.
Stop! Wait, are these bots?
They are the most players.
Stop!
Have I been thinking against real people
this time and freaking out?
When did the bot stop, though?
Because I've had a few matches now.
Uh...
Right, we're...
We're in the Nitro Dome.
Ultimate, uh, I guess?
Maybe, like, pleasant?
100% clear, stop!
You're too nice to me.
Okay, if it's bots,
then we're gonna get going.
We're gonna hit the griddy
and get going.
Can I climb up here? I'm not sure.
Oh, I wasted one of my zooms.
Uh...
I don't particularly see anyone.
Survivor.
Are you winning, son?
Uh...
I think so.
Maybe a little bit against bots?
Oh, no, one of the reeflings are stuck back there.
I think we're over here.
Okay, if I can't find any equipment
to give them an upgrade,
I guess we'll just...
Right, so when I enter the water,
it gives me, like, a zoom thing,
but it's limited. There's only three zooms.
Oh, I hear a chest.
Wow, I like how it just explodes.
I should do it that way.
Which is rather satisfying.
Want me to carry?
I've got six birds on the stream.
Sorry, six birds and errors from the game.
Okay.
Oh, my God! I can roleplay!
Hello, reefling.
What can I get for your order today?
Would you like salmon?
Would you like whatever that unidentifiable meat is?
Would you like some shrimp?
Okay, um...
Oh, you would like the cuttlefish
so that's on the menu, right?
Okay, let me just bend over.
Oh, my God!
There's an actual kitchen as well!
All these games are so cute!
I love it.
It's this one.
Okay, thank you for your chance at the extreme.
Oh, you have a hypnosis medallion?
That's so awesome!
I'm getting ready.
Don't think I won't go to Nari and order it.
Wait, what is...
Is there a chest up here?
Something is sparkling.
Or is it the till?
There.
The till just has a straight up money in it.
Where's the con?
My business is sparkling.
Ah!
Let's go kill some bugs.
Wherever they are, I don't know.
Oops, I didn't mean to do that.
I was going to hold on to that, but I guess...
Okay, let's go to this room.
Okay, Sean.
We back on Capital Sim.
I don't know why I love money making games so much.
Sorry, it's just...
Oh, the money goes up!
You already know when I'm...
When I do my little game dev stuff.
I'm 100%...
Making those incremental...
Is it incremental?
Look at that.
I've lost my...
What is this?
Oh, it blasted me back!
Okay, I like that.
I'm going to keep it.
We're to search the supply drill.
I don't know what that means.
Someone's doing something this?
I don't... I don't know.
One of these?
I don't know if I was supposed to do that.
I'm not sure.
It's the cricket from Men in Black.
Is this your first time playing Fortnite?
I played it when it first came out,
but everything looks like really new.
I don't recognize anything.
Do you want that one?
That one's got more in it for you.
I don't know what you're doing!
Oh, the zone, the zone!
Time to get a move on, Reflang!
Let's go!
I'm not going to bother with the chair.
There's 15...
I'm glad I didn't take fall damage,
but there's 15 players.
Wink, wink, lift.
Surely we'll get a real love in it.
I'm sure you will.
I don't know how to play.
I want to go car.
Get in, losers! We're going shopping!
You lost your go-see.
Mental games with a little inconsiderate.
Maybe when you're level 10.
I'm 14 right now.
I'm level 14.
Is that what we're supposed to do?
We should drive.
You guys trust me, a driver?
Trust, trust, trust.
Oh, you can break a window?
Is that everyone in?
Right, where are we going?
I'm going to use the roof like a real driver.
Where are you shooting at?
Oh, sorry. Hold on.
It's got halo controls.
Fuck it!
Let's go!
It's got halo controls where if you look a little to the left or the right, the car starts driving.
Fuck it! We're doing a hit-and-run!
Oh wait, hit-and-run doesn't count?
There's an enemy on the roof!
I don't even know how that happened.
I didn't even know enemies could do that.
Oh my god!
All the bullets are storming.
Why do they all have gauntlets on?
Stop it!
They-
That's so friendly!
Stop! They all have gauntlets!
I'm not going to make it.
Wow!
Why are they honing it on me?
Why is this- Oh my god!
They're all raiding cars!
Stop it!
You're upsetting me.
I'm not going to make it.
All the freaking bullets are in cars right now.
And they're all in gauntlets as well.
Why do they like- Is this to show them off?
How did you do that?
I don't know how you did that, but you did it.
Go and let me go.
God!
Look at how much stuff they looted.
About 500 shots fired in a match.
Yeah, because I'm spraying and praying.
Okay, check this one.
Oh my god, the recoil on a submachine gun is like violent.
The submachine gun is rough.
Is there an enemy?
Oh no, there's an enemy fling!
Are you okay?
Oh, we did it!
I didn't know we were going against the last one.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe the team get us one.
We're doing it.
This is number one.
Why don't you say GG in voice chat?
GG!
Surely we're not going to go against freaking bullets.
No.
We did it, we're winning.
Number one.
Hot is on the board right now.
Just touch down to meet.
Okay, no question mark.
Real lobbies?
Or is it really like...
You received this emote.
Shows how many crown victory royals you've won this season.
I mean, it's already on my head, so...
I don't know.
Right, I'm level 50.
Why...
Why would it not...
Sorry, I pitched it in my little board.
Put me in a human game now?
I've been playing for so long!
Are you squiddin' me right now?
What?
You are either the best or the luckiest player I've ever seen.
Don't make me admit it out loud.
Thank you for this super chat.
Admit it out loud!
The custom matches should work now that you've levelled up.
I don't know, those weren't both actions.
If she got that more, doesn't that mean it was a human game?
Maybe?
There were some people in that match.
Custom matches are done if you do custom...
No, the custom key is like only...
Hold on, I can actually show you.
The custom key is like...
It's used for private matches tournaments,
but you have to make it...
You have to make it...
With them.
I can't just...
It's not like I use the same code.
Reflings!
I'm just gonna...
Select no builds.
Zero builds.
Select...
Stop putting me in battle lobbies, I'm level 15 now.
Come on, let me get wrecked and ruined.
Okay, post your names and then I'll add you.
It's a number one victory for you.
We have a lot of matches about to get it down.
All this in the world right now.
Just touch them to make it down.
And add...
Spot and...
Enter...
Add...
And then...
Enter...
Boom.
There's my... Oh no, there's two of you.
Okay, it must be the first result.
There's only one.
There's only one, okay?
Okay, let me write down the names.
These guys come in the lobby.
Rinn...
It's so useful.
It literally sounds like Smog.
Um...
John, Omni, Present...
And last but not least, they accept...
Question mark.
Did you get the friend request?
I swear, if you got open make on, I'm gonna fart down it.
You gotta turn that open make off right now, unless...
Wait, if it's console, is it always open?
No, it can't be.
No, it used to be open.
Ah, no, the keyboard taping as he tries to close the open make.
Again here, I heard that fart.
Oh no, did the other friend request not go through?
Wait, why does that not work?
Okay, spa, I'm gonna try you again.
Wasn't I not you that I tried to get?
Did I forget to hit send?
No, you didn't come up.
Can he be your name?
Okay, that didn't...
Plus, I've already played with you, you goober.
I heard that fart.
Okay, bear teddy.
Wait, why is this not working?
No, you guys are taping and names aren't real.
Are you trolling me?
It doesn't say you're real players.
Okay, it says you're a real player.
Okay, so we have...
Well, if you come in...
I wrote your name down.
Okay, yeah, you can come in.
We have Ruin, John and Sanix.
So we're super fast, we're super destructive.
And we're super omnipresent, which means all-knowing.
So...
We're like gods?
Okay, mm-hmm.
So if we're like gods, the team name is gonna be...
I don't know.
God's Prime?
We're gonna be called the Prime Gods.
Why not?
We are Prime Gods.
Because we're just so good like that.
Let's go.
Hey, wait, wait, wait.
Waiting for three more players to ready up.
You stinker-tins.
Team 2 is the best team to watch.
I am...
You are in it!
That's why...
Strong John...
Runic.
Honestly, that's probably better than what I came up with.
I said Prime Gods.
This is the team name.
So we've had the Chikmul fumblings.
We've had the Reckoning of the Radical Reflings processors.
We've had the Giddies and they're the Prime Gods.
Oh, yeah.
Ready up.
Waiting for magic.
Hydration check, Reflings.
Corner time.
We ate.
Run a train on your enemies with pleasure.
I also run a train on my allies too.
Can you see that?
Ready?
I don't know.
I'm glowing.
Literally, I'm glowing because the Reflings have been inking on me.
Are you real?
Are you an NPC?
Be honest.
Look into my eyes.
Are you a real player?
Okay.
I think you've still got some balls.
What?
They're just randomly emoting.
Where did the bot stop?
That's it.
I'm opening up another tab.
Failed tonight.
When do bot stop?
What level?
At what point do you stop playing bot?
Level 10 or win three games?
That was from three years ago though.
I feel like this shit's probably...
Where are we going?
I don't know.
You know what?
I've not been...
I've not been a brutal beachhead.
Let's just go all the way to the end.
We'll raid it to the end.
You run the train on enemies, then allies run the train on you.
True, three games.
I've already played three games though.
Okay, we're gonna drop right at the end.
Wee!
He's...
No fighting.
You'll have to...
He's cleaning the vomit.
I have to watch the radio.
I even know you're getting into my lobbies,
because I'm an Australian server,
but I don't even...
Okay, there's an ampie?
Not to alert anyone,
but it seems like we're not the only ones here somehow.
God, we're in fricking junk town.
Oh, we got the hit.
The hit game?
No, we're not really a hit game anymore.
Right, okay.
New location.
We're at the assault rifle.
Happy days for me.
Oh, replays!
I get to ink on you.
And there's a gun here too.
Where are my replays?
Would you all like to gather for our daily inkening?
Even though there's enemies right there.
Okay, there's enemies first and then we ink.
New...
Uh-huh.
Okay, this is the ball.
Come on.
Fartnate, you're ruining it.
You're ruining it.
Why?
Can I not get a human?
Please don't think I won't revisit this game.
I'm actually really enjoying myself on it.
I really enjoy playing with you guys.
I should hit them in the butt.
Oh, no, sorry.
There's one right there.
Okay.
They didn't exactly drop much lid.
Woo!
Oh, I didn't mean to do that, but it's okay.
Everything's fine.
Okay, are you ready for our group inkening?
Ready?
Okay, everyone come here for the group inkening.
I'm squirting.
Thank you for letting me squirt for the first time.
I appreciate it.
We did it.
Oh, there's a chance.
Okay.
I'm going to mostly get a little bit of ammunition in my life.
A little bit of...
A little bit of monocles.
Almost.
A little bit of aces all on me.
A little bit of earwax.
All on me.
A little bit of she who comes.
A little bit of hazard to shove my face in here.
Fun little bit.
A little bit of mercy.
To make me plead for mercy.
A little bit.
Woo!
I ain't that fast.
Take that, Mr. Bot.
And this, Mr. Bot.
How are you?
Assist.
Yeah, assist my art hole.
Reefling Siggum.
I might even caca.
Wait, someone else is shooting him too?
Or is that you guys shooting him?
Hold on.
What is he doing?
What are you doing?
Is that the...
To shove your face in?
Yeah, like a mortar bullet?
Why...
Oh, here he is.
How do they always have those mythic gloves on?
Oh, he's rolling...
He's running over!
You know, that's the...
What is it?
Did he call it, like, auto by death or something like that?
Okay, that's not bad.
That's not bad.
We are just gonna head for the middle of the map
and beat up every bot along the way.
Because I don't know, I...
I'm not sure.
I might...
What I'll do is play offline
to, like, leveled up.
And when I'm satisfied that I'm going against humans,
we'll do another stream snipe on Fortnite
because I'm really struggling to understand
why it's not giving us humans.
I refuse to believe that there's a lot of humans in this game
when it's, like, yeah, there's, like, almost 400,000 players,
so I'm...
I don't know.
I'm finding it hard to...
to believe them when it's, like...
I don't know.
I will take two hours to download Fortnite.
How long are you streaming?
Oh!
I was gonna...
I'm struggling to get human lobbies.
I don't know.
Mummy, check their names on the bottom left
after you tell them to see if they have bots
and their names are real ones.
Little Mia, 50, Bryson, 6'6", Pickle, 60.
Yeah, these are the same format over and over.
Mate, this one's very bottom.
Alright, I helped.
I helped.
You saw that.
You saw me helping.
Dude, I didn't see that coming.
Where are...
I can't reach...
to ever to download the...
I think the last one looked really,
even given off too much for a bot,
movement. I don't I don't know what would change. Like what's going on?
Oh no, what happened? Did you fall to your death?
I might go.
Let's keep this one.
I'm sure it's humans with a lower skill level with that number of hot sprinkles in it.
Is it because I'm on Aussie server? Right, hold on. Right, after this one we're going to pick American servers, okay?
Well, it's 8am. Is it really that much?
Servers over here? Tell you what, right, we'll play one more after this.
And we'll swap to American servers on purpose.
And if we're still against bots, I'll just play on my own and then we'll actually try and stream snipe next time.
Because we'll know what's up, right? Okay, let's go to the middle of the map to kill as much as possible.
I searched all these servers so easier.
Home advantage gone. Real and true though.
It's probably better that you guys have better ping than me.
If we actually do go against humans because there's no way.
Name location. Let's check out my map.
See, look, it's like getting less gray.
When you first start playing, you are put into lobbies with bots but it slowly integrates more women.
So there is a chance.
I really just keep playing.
Well, that seemed a bit human-like.
I don't know.
I don't know if it's copium but...
Why is this place so loud? It's so loud in here.
Am I perfect?
I mean, I'd rather not, but...
Two hours to download.
My download is still at 24%. Oh, no!
There's a lot going on in that pit.
I need a headache.
If the glasses don't give me a headache first, that load location.
Cabbage! My cabbages!
I'm going to end up getting hurt.
Exploring without the reeflings.
Watch me not be with a reefling for five seconds and then I'll just instantly die.
I have to spectate them for the rest of the games.
I think they're doing fine.
There's a loophole.
My nephew's better than me.
I like to watch off the pathway in.
I'm being brave!
It's totally not because I know that the odds of me coming across through people are really low right now.
Mummy has abandoned her reeflings?
Are the reeflings not keeping up with my marker?
We need to go in the middle.
Oh, they're in a car.
Who's driving this car?
I'm too late to download the game again.
Don't worry, we'll most likely play it again because I actually really am enjoying this.
We're just... I didn't realize...
I don't know.
I just thought we wouldn't get bought.
I don't know why, because obviously it makes sense for new players.
But I didn't think...
No, you're not destroying Olympus.
We can't be bothered.
We're going for it.
I need to go in there.
I've got to go.
Sadly, otherwise I'm going to get carsick.
Oh no, don't get carsick.
I have violent carsick, so I completely get you.
Please don't worry.
They destroyed Azura's temple.
It's actually funny how Azura's lore kind of developed.
Because she was supposed to be a lot more like your her servant, but it kind of changed.
You know, you can tell by her first month, her first month of Patreon scripts,
I made it very like your her servant, but that didn't really come to be.
Like, as I said, obviously I didn't know the girls before they, you know, got hold of them type thing.
And it's just interesting like how I theorized though it would work out like this, it would work out like that.
And we're like, please do this, please do that.
And that angle just kind of completely, it says there's like a chest right here.
Oh, I'm needing like a blue one.
Is there an actual thing?
Please, just give me a blue gun.
We're going to go kill bots because they'll drop more.
Dude, or what are we shooting?
Dude, they're just killing them all.
There's shields.
Sonic, you need to fill your shields.
You can force to drink. Yeah, that's right.
Listen to your mom.
Reeflings are so well behaved, they always listen.
Everyone's shields are filled with that naturopath.
Oh, you want to fist me?
It's just flying.
Do you not take full damage if you just heat yourself?
Well, let's find out.
Oh, they've got a cooldown, so I can't.
I don't want to fall down.
How do you jump?
Oh!
That's very low, please.
No more.
Can't take anything being low.
Where are the bots?
Why aren't they coming closer?
So I don't need to swap servers then?
It's just kind of a timed thing as I level up.
Scanning for bots.
Oh, we need to play Star Wars Battlefront, actually.
Liz, are we following San?
Okay, let's go.
Okay, I like this mode of transport.
I'm not doing it the best, but it's actually very efficient.
Oh, there we go.
Now hold on, let me in the fight too.
Hold on a minute, hold on a minute, let me in the fight.
Don't put me out yet, coach.
Okay, I can see that I put mobility stuff in.
She's insane, third party.
We've lost the command post.
Yeah, you know Star Wars Battlefront?
My dad let me play it all the time.
And I got to kill the piggie wiggies on the DLCs.
The DLCs were free, they just pushed them.
Wait, aren't we out of the zone?
No, we're in it.
We're just going to the edge of the map.
Oh my god, this is the North Pole outpost where everyone dies.
I'll pick that.
Don't mind further.
Okay, and then if we go this way.
I don't know how the render distance works with a heat seeker.
Are we sniping?
Oh, holy shit, what's that fall off?
No, no, no, hold on, let me reload, don't move.
Don't move.
No, I don't know what the fall is.
How are you supposed to guess what the fall off is?
I have no idea.
Alright, let's get some good aiming.
Get some good aiming, where are they?
There's two of them, right?
Come on.
Get them.
Cannot sprint, low energy.
Are you still not dead after that?
Are you serious?
It runs away.
I finally get into a fight and it's just like, I'm out.
Ah, there's one of my rooflings there.
Ah, is this a real?
Are they real?
Why are these two of you down?
You're making me scared.
Are we against real people?
I don't know.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I think that may be a real person.
Oh my god, that candle looks real though.
I'm getting hurt.
I don't know what you want me to do.
Here, what?
Okay, right, I need focus.
I need focus.
Focus.
Right, lovely.
Oh my god.
They're kind of real.
Are they?
I can't tell.
I honestly can't.
I'm getting so confuzzled.
There's two down in that place I just saw.
I don't know if they're real or not.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I get over there.
Oh my god.
Ah, come on, the sniper takes so long.
Where'd you go?
Where'd you go, yellow?
Hey, could you imagine though if I hit that?
I'd be like the coolest player ever, you know?
Oh, I missed.
Okay, I hit the wrong, I forgot.
Like, forget this.
This isn't working.
Huh?
Oh.
They're like rendered this thing so far.
There's still a twat bag and a list over there.
I don't know if we just need to go down and like literally attack.
A bit more up.
Okay, up, up, up.
Oh, it cracked them.
I got 58.
Oh.
I don't know why the bots are honing in on us.
Oh, it cracked.
I don't know.
I mean, if we're happy.
Oh no, this one's all the way over there, right?
We need to move.
Okay, this one's over here.
So let's just move for this one.
And if we kill a few baddies on the way, then...
Wait, are they getting attacked?
Hmm.
She's cracking.
I'm cracking up.
I'm just using the overheat scan, by the way.
Before you're like, why are you aiming like that?
It's the heat scan.
And use the sleep.
All right, okay.
Let's just make a little cheeky leg over to the next zone.
Because it's literally about to close in on us, like right now.
I hear things.
Oh.
Give it a rest.
What's this?
Ow, that's not friendly.
It's friendly at all.
And I'm no out of position.
I'm no out of position.
Please!
Actually losing supports!
Oh my god, I'm actually losing supports.
Hold on, I need to heal up.
I went too far without my rivelling.
I don't have any heals on me.
Oopsies.
Oopsies, I'm just going to hide behind this rock
and hope that the old snake won't end before me.
Oh, I'm getting pissed on.
Thank you.
I'm getting screwed in.
Oh, thank you, the Lord of the Boots.
Six out of five gifted members.
I'm not even playing well.
Why are you gifted new memberships?
It's literally never pleased with terribly in my life.
I'm not going to make it.
There's some flat behind that rock.
I don't know.
Stop happening.
Oh my god.
It's never ending.
That was so unlucky.
Oh no!
What am I doing?
We lost the boss.
Oh no!
That was so good.
Oh yeah.
Oh no!
That was bizarre.
Nothing was going right.
Magnet was busted.
No way that was a boss.
That was like really weird gameplay.
That was really weird.
There's like a weird background statistic audio important.
Can you hear that?
It's like.
What is that?
It's not me.
I only have this up.
It was a refling's mic.
I'm so sorry.
That was your mic.
I am so sorry.
Whoopsies.
I forget it was me making but it wasn't seen in him.
Sorry refling.
I didn't mean to call you out like that.
I didn't realize.
Okay.
We'll play one more.
And if it.
If it.
Leave parties and then do it like that.
Okay.
That's fine.
From my friend.
Yep.
And then we'll get new refling in.
Okay.
I don't know.
Sorry.
I was like, oh that's weird.
There's like some weird white noise going on in this game.
The refling's open mic.
Sorry.
Okay.
Who have I not played with that would like to play.
I think this might be our last one.
Just because of.
Just because.
Sorry.
No.
It's fine.
Let's have a big team.
Just because.
I'm going to play offline to get out of this fricking ball.
Such a.
Because the queen joins the fortnight grains.
Literally.
It's so good.
It's such a good stream snipe game as well.
Because it's free to play.
Which I like.
Because unfortunately I'm actually playing.
I'm doing a game next.
That I've not done before.
Let me write down the names.
Met a.
Oracle.
Not to be confused with Polo.
Okay.
Let's try again.
Rest time after.
Yeah.
A few things that you do in the background.
So this might.
As I said.
This might be our last one.
I can't wait for Halo tomorrow.
Yeah.
I can get my rest.
Okay.
Does that work?
It did.
Okay.
That worked.
Let's see.
Can you guys carry me against the box is the real question.
I don't know.
Yeah.
Right.
What should our team be called?
We've got.
Um.
Okay.
We've got a family guy character.
We've got toga.
And then we've got a default.
Default.
Maybe we should name a show like default toga guy.
I don't know.
What should we name this view?
Don't forget to change it from oceanic.
I don't know.
Hmm.
Thank you again for the gifted members.
It's the booty lord and congrats to those who caught them.
Put your face.
Okay.
We'll call the team peter.
Peter.
The yandere is here.
Okay.
So.
The yandere is here.
You're playing my climb.
What's going on here?
Okay.
Ready up.
Time to ready up.
We've got a little snake thing going on.
I don't know what that is.
People didn't.
All suits and protective IRP was cool.
Is that a type of game mode or am I being dumb?
They've got some nice skins.
Victory Royale.
Yeah.
We're about to get down.
The accent spawn.
Peter.
What are you doing?
Okay.
That's awful.
Mark, cool.
Please ready up.
We can do it.
Peter.
The yandere is here.
What's behind you?
Peena.
Wake up.
The person the A looks like Targaryen.
The brain roll.
I still let you weigh.
You guys have so much.
this right let's try and sync up everyone do the default dance right now yes
right everyone right okay we're trying to do it at the same time right you
ready all right three no no I count down right three two one go no wait for
me right ready no stop right brought together free right three two one go
okay that's not gonna work out right we'll try again okay three two one go
no it's even the same amount the delay is too strong wait hold on a minute
not to be dramatic or anything but that took a whole minute to find us a
game does that mean does that mean the bros delay is next week does that mean
we're in a real game because if it's filled by both then it would take a long
time right but if it's filled with humans I think I think we're against real
people this time it only took us two and a half hours to get against real people
hold on right take a look around so those with the box that's two ball groups
wait a minute aren't you the chicken from before I can't see your name
hold on a minute you look like you're real hmm so there's two ball groups but
like if you look around there's what's doing stuff that's not me my mate don't
you mean another way around no I didn't get in our man real people it's go time
more real players than before I don't know are you both I don't know I feel like
we're against the real people this time
they can just make sure where should we go I've not been to Grand Glacier when
we go there okay let's go to Grand Glacier
Peter the real enemies are here and then we're gonna get annihilated Peter you
don't understand I'm gonna watch a video on how to shoot them I think because I'm
Aussie servers it's like nice and awful and I don't know it's because I'm playing with
the rooflings from America as well it's taking that into account because they've
no go
please I'm so sorry her voice is very good for like repetitive sentences that are
like satisfying at least the game isn't doing the frame rate lag thing it was
that's it like now that we're like discovering like the locations the
games like yeah no I literally cannot get enough to use the door like that of
course he gets in right away you argued it fitting into things aren't you
briefly why is it not discovering it on the map even though I'm in it I'm
literally in Glacier and it's like I had 370 ping I am not surprised I am not
surprised
hold on
what and here
Oh
replays you'll never guess I almost died to a freaking ball oh my god I thought
stop it don't ever do that again you almost made me dying are we under fire
that took me I was like so slow to respond to that as well I was like getting
beaten up and I was like okay he reeflings tickling me oh my god you're
being a spank him spank him that's what we think of him right I have I have ink
time
okay I have ink if you guys want to group up I can ink all over you right now
where is he coming over he's coming are you ready are you playing drums while
I'm inking on you how dare you I like how the copyrighted music isn't playing so
you're literally just going side-by-side on it oh yeah this is the best thing ever
sorry I don't care no shop I'm having fun
ooh I hear
it's in the elevator
there's a lift
chock chock with you
where are you
where am I still in the house
under the stairs maybe
gank gank gank gank
reeflings gets ganked in here
wait
I'm so bad I can hear it
the box would leave us alone to our private time
right where's he going
I guess we'll make our way to
reckless reeflings
that scared me so did I go
okay those are real names in the chat though
there are I think we are getting to the point where like more than
dash power
hi mama I have to go but it was fun watching you and everyone meet up players and
I wish I could have got a real player but maybe next time
love you love you to the reeflings don't worry we'll definitely play again I like
that it's a free access game as I said I think we're definitely gonna be playing
can we walk through this
we're gonna play
which is a play game but well I'll do the same thing where our idea is on steam
and then I remove and then we play next and then we'll just keep up with those
I quite like doing it that way I don't know I don't know how you guys feel about doing it
oh you didn't even take the opportunity to spray me fine I'll spray myself
give myself a facial with my own well I don't have it
there is a chest up there
you got it
is that well you know what I've got more healing
I have all the healing in the world
thank you very much dash power for the super chat
I love very much I too I'm gonna have to play off loan because it's been a many a
clam juice
yes it is a pay game but I do like focusing on games that are free
oh knocked them for a whole 19
actually I need to be a bit careful because there are humans in this game
don't be too don't be too cocky okay
don't don't be like Skywalker because I'm Han Solo don't get cocky
there are humans we're not all but
I need to reload
yeah okay that's what we're doing
spank spank spank spank spank spank spank
did you drop oh Nuka Kula
enjoy
how about a stealth
I don't think I need stealth I just need a bear whip and drink
vermin tape more like ancient tape
hold on
oh my soundboard wait hold on let me open up my soundboard
wait hold on hold that joke hold the joke hold it hold it hold it
vermin tape more like ancient tape
thank you thank you
just respect your surroundings
what are you doing
why are you role-playing being on the show
I thought I was bad for role-playing Grimini as butter
guns
how are you
you blew up you literally dropped a bomb that's how nasty your ship was
you literally
okay um
like I don't want to I don't want to brag about anything
are we getting in
I don't know where we're going but you can take me on a journey why not
literally take me to the toilet
the real question is why are you peeking
I'm allowed to do what I want to the reef lens okay
we're actually by my royal decree
of being scrawny
that the reeflings will let me do whatever I please to them
oh no whoa
I was gonna take can you wait they're called gimme Chris
that doesn't really seem very gauntly
are they alone
hmm
I'm not sure how much uh
did you know the devs of airman 2 are testing a versus mode
um I'm not sure I'm not sure
uh
can I first look
what's really good about things that
you
by your royal decree I am allowed to what should be
and what that's hold on we need to help the reeflings
or not reefling is fully self-sufficient doesn't need me
I don't know what like this all-round enforcer stuff is
I'm sure I'll learn at some point but right now it's not
oh my god this is the worst aim down the slide ever
no don't give me that again that's awful
what happens to a reefling who doesn't let you take
you ever played the game of fire truck before
so I'll put my hand on your knee
and I'll keep slowly going up your leg okay
and then when you say red light I'll stop
okay
there you go red light
and I say fire trucks don't stop for red light
there's a loss to the storm the bots are literally
looking at themselves right let's go I guess lavishing layer
it's like
where is this way yeah let's go a bit more in the circle
just give me one more turn
what is this
Riz 1000 I'm not sure if that's Riz
I think that's more Ray you know like
you know
but whatever makes sense
she triggered my swallery foot
oh speaking of swallowing hi Jason check
what
oh get in
let's drive
would you like to get on the roof
wait does Mermintine have it some friends list or
I'll have to add you something but it's not my deal
I'll just delete at the end
dancing dancing dancing
oh she's so happy and cute I do love her hair
I have to admit it's design
what strongy you can't just say every time someone has to
make people hear it's peak design
what
who gave you a license
did you get it out of a cereal box
okay we're discovering a new area lavish layer
I haven't discovered fuck it let's go there if you have not
made it
I know the zone's probably about to like tell us to turn right back around
moment time social
Steam list for sure
Steam friends list it is
wait is that bad
I'm not being dumb dumb
you have to stare at my butt while you drive
maybe we'll just manually walk
tangling the water
whoa
have I seen them damn bullets using these fucking things again
as if it works as a shield
drop it right now
I mean I get that it works as a shield but seriously drop it
mark drink
your fuck up
right let me quickly discover this cafe hello okay
because I'm not discovered it yet
now it's not full of bots there are still humans on the map but
people will be able to see who you're friends with
is it my just private
oh maybe I can't learn
new location discovered
we did it
I like did a big little chunk of the map
whoa I kept running
what the heck I kept running while I was looking at the map there
wait what are they doing
okay let's turn back let's turn back
I think my refunds are in trouble
oh my god I'm not there for them
come on the one time I'm not there for them
okay let's fucking go
fuck it
don't worry me and pita I'm gonna help you reclaim this okay
pita and I are here
don't die
make sure you use your chug jugs
and your heels use your bandages
I've gained the god it gained the gnaw
alright okay we're fine we're fine
where is the new
where is the new zone it's coming
okay I keep running by actually
collect ammo oh I'm about to get an achievement to collect an ammo
what
also me are we getting bots
I don't know maybe that isn't a bot
oh no it says 2017 in their name
it's like an actual title
cleanup
oh don't sleep
oh my god wait what's this an assault rifle for me
oh my god
yeah he called
alright sorry red dot size
okay I literally just killed a seven year old
I saw that
are we going up there
seems like the reeflings are getting
oh you can drop in
whoa whoa whoa jeez
no point was to get me up there
did you get him
what is this
this face
are we playing capture the flag right now
I think we're playing capture the flag
and the zone
I don't want to
I don't want to say that we need to like get a move on but brother zone
are we gonna even make it
what happens if we stay here do we need to
what happens can we like fly again
wait the reeflings aren't moving
so surely there's something about to happen
the zone it's making me nervous
right okay what now
we're about to die
and you you're bothering about loot
how do we move
fuck it reeflings I'm sorry
but I don't understand
oh no no no
I'm gonna be honest I thought it was gonna open up a parachute
because I was on a freaking level
you can't just go go on without me
go on without me
go on reeflings it's fine
I don't know if you can do it
I thought because I was up in the air
it was gonna open up a parachute
I don't know why it wouldn't
oh my god he's literally not gonna make it
is any of us gonna survive
he's literally gonna pop his clothes
carrying me
oh my god
drop her in red she'll die in the storm
alright
bruh I literally never
yeah take the gun it's legendary
I literally
come on you have to admit
I was up in the sky so why wouldn't it not
like be like yeah sure you're fine
no
I told you I was worried about the storm
did any of you believe me
no
literally
wait you're puking because I died in game
mommy's gone
I didn't feel
oh you can rev me
oh no
oh no no
what the fuck was that
pistole
oh my god give me anything please
how did I get that reefling back
he saved me
how did I get him in
recharging
that's not what I want to hear
carry on without Peter
oh
what
what the fuck
how did he got voice mod on
what the fuck is that
that's terrifying
how did I
I don't know how to rev me
a nitro splash
oh no that's a good thing
okay I think we can rev him
I need shield though
I don't want to drop any shields on that
hey I'm back everyone and I'm shield
we're going to lose in a fight
because we're fucking around with clone fish
hey I'm back everyone
literally me
me if I was a lollipop streamer
hey I'm back everyone
has anyone got a shield
sorry has anyone got a shield
I don't think anyone has
but
can it reefling voice
oh my god you need to
do a voice line of what it sounds like
when a reefling is
okay we need to go over here
let's pay attention to the zone
I can't get up okay sorry hold on
mommy can't get up give me a second
one and three men
okay I think it's definitely good to have those mobility pack
I understand now like
once you take away no build
like the add mobility stuff
back in like oh wait hold on
I have one
hold on let me try hard
where I just hear a lot of really good
you over here and we just want to kill
kill
oh you did it!
we did it
we did it I'm level 20
oh no I'm 19 right before
victory Royale
you have first knife we buffed
get down get down
look at all that HP
jeez
right
return to lobby
I'm gonna call it there before
I start having a break because
my eyeballs are getting used to the glasses
a little too much
that was so fun
100%
we are doing that again
like
that was so fun
so so fun
I'll definitely level up offline
so we get full
human lobbies
because
that was
just so fun
I thoroughly enjoyed that
I hope you guys enjoyed that
that just literally was
that felt like a gaming session
between mates you've not been able to catch up with
for a while or whatever
that was just absolutely 10 out of 10
I love that and thank you so so much
I literally can't even say how thankful I am
that was just so fun
I'll see if I can redirect into someone
I don't know if anyone's on right now
the upstairs is offline
I don't know if Emmy's up by then
I'm gonna check
I don't know if any of the girls are on
I've been really trying
as I said
next time we play Fortnite I will be
fully leveled up
hmm
there is
no embers
no
sheepsters
is anyone coming up soon? Emmy should be on
the upstairs
unlucky coach
right
I
will
do into me because I actually
might have an ASMR collab with her
that one is for you
as a thank you
no one else until the collab which is a bit later
yeah
was a part of the only team that didn't win
kind of embarrassed
I am embarrassed Rieflin
I got really overwhelmed
at the end of that last fight
I have my crown see
I have my crown
but I had a lot of fun
it was so good
and I really enjoyed that
I can't wait to do that again
thank you to the members in particular
that are understanding I am delaying the chest
1v1
and tomorrow
we're playing Halo Combat
Evolved
my heart rate monitor has been on for ages
hold on let me take it off
you can listen to me take off my heart rate
monitor
but
yeah my heart rate was probably
way lower than it normally is
em
cause
yeah literally that was just like
a hoot and a holler and fun
oh sorry that was my heart rate monitor
it was like a
it was actually pretty
what was low for the stream sorry
the
oh my god I can't take off the fricking strap
get off of me
okay there I've got the strap I've got the strap
oh my heart was low for the stream
yeah literally like I felt so relaxed
and just playing with it
it's been like under 80
this is literally the most relaxed I've ever been on a stream
we're waiting till
I should have left the heart rate monitor on
and you'll see it speeds up right at the end stream
yay
you're cool under fire
I don't know if it went intense during Dead by Dailer
or not
relax gaming with moma
here with the strap
okay thank you so so much my little reef links
I'm gonna redirect into someone outside of Vealor as always
if they ain't one of us
do treat them with
as respect as you be
until you learn someone's kind of things you know
when you were hunting the girls it was
not me
I'm sure there's a limmy clip
of him playing the killer on Dead by Daylight
and his heart rate is like 4 or something
because he's so relaxed like running around
slashing people
that is funny as anything
thank you everyone as well for your patience
but
just so there's no brain worms
like no one on my friends list and all that
no brain worms oh you can't see
but no brain worms
it's okay to have brain worms but look
my friends list is all good
I'm just being chilling
I don't know about
vermin tide if I have to make a new esteem account
I will because I just don't want any
issues
bye strongy
bye bye weathlands okay you look after yourself
and as always you'll get a kiss
for every win okay
so one kiss
thank you team chikmo fumblings
two kiss
mmmm
thank you
rekenin of the radical reeflings
plus scissors
mmmm
thank you get his
for the very good games
and the one for the prime gods
mmmm
thank you thank you
and last but certainly not least
peter the game daring is here
mmmm
thank you so so much for hanging in and I'll see you
over as later okay
five kisses for five victory royals
even if we didn't win them all
you still have one in my heart okay
I see you tomorrow
for some hero combat of all
this time I won't hide behind my chair
mmmm
see you tomorrow okay bye bye
and always be nice to every direct into
okay
end the protocol
mmmm victory
oh yeah
mmmm